comúnmente las organizaciones cuando las
visitamos los ejecutivos dicen cosas
como estas
falta comunicación en esta empresa que
sucede que tienen que mejorar su
comunicación y además de eso parece que
trabajan solos como si trabajarán con
islas es lo que normalmente escuchamos a
los grandes ejecutivos dentro de las
organizaciones y la gran pregunta que
todo el mundo se hace es como como cómo
desarrolló una comunicación para un
trabajo en equipo quiero contarles que
en una publicación que se llama
revolución salió hace algunos años donde
está una investigación de limitar del
instituto del instituto para la
integración de américa latina y el
caribe en donde advierten los riesgos y
los retos que están teniendo todas las
empresas y sobre todo las personas de
cara a la robótica y en la inteligencia
artificial
en ese sentido justamente el mismo
director el señor gustavo félix afirma
los robots
van a destruir reemplazar y crear
empleos simultáneamente y esto es una
llamada de atención para otros porque en
ese mismo estudio también se afirma que
aproximadamente el cincuenta y tantos
por ciento en los países donde los
empleos tienen una gran probabilidad de
ser automatizados quiere decir que el
trabajo se puede reemplazar o robótica e
inteligencia artificial y lo mismo en un
estudio que se hizo en argentina y
uruguay al 65% es en este punto donde es
muy relevante prestar atención si a la
gran tecnología que se está vendiendo a
la revolución tecnológica pero a su vez
también es importante que apoyemos a una
revolución educativa como introduciendo
las habilidades blandas y las of skirts
y porque esto es importante porque las
op skills o las habilidades blandas son
los comportamientos que no se pueden
robotizar hoy por hoy las empresas de
headhunting las empresas que están
reclutando personal hacia las empresas
lo que está haciendo es valorar más las
habilidades blandas e incluso los
y la experiencia porque porque un
profesional inteligente sin habilidades
blandas es como hablar de un auto de
alta gama sin ruedas o sin llantas va a
avanzar si solamente que lo hace
lentamente y con mucho esfuerzo además
de eso justamente las habilidades
blancas que más te están en una
organización que más la solicita es el
desarrollo de comunicación y trabajo en
equipo conjuntamente con las habilidades
de adaptación al cambio e innovación
la gran pregunta que todos nos
formulamos en este sentido es esta cómo
desarrollamos una excelente comunicación
para el trabajo en equipo yo quisiera
por favor que todos los que están aquí
presentes imagínate una una caja fuerte
delante de ti una caja fuerte que además
está cerrada
imagínate que dentro de ella hay una
serie de herramientas que van a
contribuir para que tú alcances todas
tus metas estos sueños
imagínate que toda esa riqueza está ahí
adentro te gustaría tener la clave de
esa caja fuerte para poder abrirla y
tener las herramientas para alcanzar
todas tus metas y tus sueños
y qué bueno porque justo eso es lo que
viene muy bien van a obtener esa clave
pero sabes que te voy a decir algo esa
clave está dentro de ti
yo lo que voy a mostrar es el camino
como tú vas a poder conseguir esa clave
para conseguir todo esto para eso me voy
a basar en dos modelos el primer modelo
estudiado por william edward germán de
los cuadrantes cerebrales escenas o en
dos modelos para desarrollar esto él fue
el gestor de capacitaciones y general
electric aproximadamente por los años
1970 se canceló con los modelos
existentes de roger spirit hemisferio
izquierdo y derecho están de mclean que
habla sobre el cerebro corticales y
subcorticales el problema lírico en ese
sentido funciona estos dos modelos y
cree en su propio modelo de cuadrantes
cuatro cuadrantes muy interesantes que
ahorita los vamos a ver aún más de eso
saca cuatro estilos de pensamiento
mientras te explico todo esto lo
aprendes yo te pido algo porque hay dos
pasos para poder abrir esa caja fuerte
lo primero auto conocerte para conocerte
para conocer a los demás y segundo va a
ser está claro entonces el primer paso
auto conocerte
mientras técnico escritor lo aprendes
te pido por favor que te vayas
identificando con qué características
dependiendo del cuadro de cada cuadrante
tú te caracterizas si vamos a ver por
ejemplo el frontal izquierdo comúnmente
llamado el directivo el controlador el
experto tiene ciertas características
como estas por ejemplo lógico orientada
lamenta matemático toma decisiones y
dirección no personal son los que son
mucho más técnicos y además son lógicos
y analíticos si las características que
nombra ti se describen entonces podrías
decir si se describen muchísimo
muchísimo y te sientes como especial y
dragón esas características podría
decirte es tu área de preferencia si las
características que leo ti dices mira
más o menos como que me siento cómodo
sería tu área de uso y finalmente si es
que para nada esas características te
describen entonces sería tu área incluso
de rechazo
vamos con la segunda base al izquierdo
el bazar izquierdo es el organizador es
más como el controlador
y las características que tienen son
justamente estas secuencial gustan de
los procesos y procedimientos además son
efectivos y eficientes van directamente
hacia la meta son los que planifican los
que organizan significas con estas
características excelentes estarías
henares preferencia de uso vamos al
tercero y ahora ya nos vamos al
hemisferio derecho al otro lado el apoyo
el colaborador el comunicador vas al
derecho estas personas son las personas
empáticas cercanas son las habladora son
las que se retiren de ese poder de
comunicación además le gusta integrar a
la gente quiere que todos vayan juntos a
la fiesta y además también le gusta
desarrollar a las personas y finalmente
el cuarto cuadrante o cuadrante de es el
expresivo motivador es el estratega
muchas veces es el innovador también
aquí tiene un pensamiento más abstracto
a estas personas además son mucho más
creativas son innovadoras y sobre todo
toman riesgos son persuasivos y
visionarios ahí están normalmente en los
innovadores
y creativos entonces han de
identificando t qué características te
identificas más con estos cuadrantes
ahora la gran pregunta es una vez que yo
un auto conozco y digo ok yo pertenezco
este cuadrante la gran pregunta es y
ahora como yo me comunico con las
personas que son diferentes a mí porque
las personas que se pelean se parecen a
mí va a ser muy fácil poder de comunicar
porque tienen tu mismo lenguaje tienen
tus mismas expresiones tienen tu mismo
proceso mental
ahora como yo hago sobre todo en los
trabajos en la parte laboral con los
equipos de trabajo como para comunicarme
con personas que están fuera de mi
cuadrante es más están en el cuadrante
de rechazo de las características que yo
tengo y por eso van a ocurrir la flexión
aquí te doy las claves de cómo
comunicarte con cada cuadrante
independientemente si tú estás o no
estás allí por ejemplo como el directivo
controlador experto aquí tienes que
estar sumamente preparado para poder
hablar con estas personas además de eso
bassat en ellos habla solamente de los
objetivos y por favor evita emociones
con las personas que están en ese
cuadrante las personas que están en el
segundo cuadrante reflexivo estudioso
organizador con estas personas tienen
que ser secuencial solamente a promesas
que puedas cumplir
cuidado con eso y además documenta y
bastante en datos y cifras este proceso
de comunicación que les estoy explicando
aquí lo estudio las retras elíseo de
trans metrix una persona que por 30 años
estudiado e investigado como las
personas responden en los modelos de
educación y además de eso
han resuelto más de un millón de
personas diciendo cuál debería ser la
comunicación de la persona ideal persona
real creando una base de conocimientos
tremenda de que se comunica mejor vamos
al tercero apoyo el colaborador el
comunicador con esta persona se puede
ser más empático pueden compartir
experiencias dale el tiempo con esta
persona
si tienes que darle tiempo a construir
una relación son las personas más
empáticas y finalmente en el último
cuadrante qué es
apoyo colaborador comunicador con estas
personas perdón el expresivo motivador y
estrategia con estas personas tienen que
ser totalmente casual llenan la
conversación
con anécdotas con historias y además
permiten a la persona que hable y además
invitarlo a soñar
son las formas como tú te puedes
comunicar mejor con cada uno de los
cuadrantes y antes de pasar a la
siguiente parte es por qué es importante
esto yo les quiero contar una
experiencia en una organización donde
fuimos nos contrataron para hacer un
trabajo de integración la gente no
entendía por qué un grupo de analistas
trabajaban como islas solos éramos los
ingenieros que trabajar aisladamente y
en los quería integrar los ingenieros no
entendían por qué la jefa era tan
comunicativa los traía a cada momento
para que se reúnan y desde su
perspectiva era como para ir a hablar
cosas banales y sin sentido se hizo un
taller de integración se pudieron
identificar cada uno evidentemente la
gerenta era un cuadrante ese el rojo y
los analistas están en el cuadrante 1
frontal izquierdo
de esta manera desde autoconocerse
comprendieron las necesidades del otro e
inmediatamente empezaron a integrarse
por lo tanto es muy importante auto
comprenderte para poder comprender a los
demás con este punto listo ahora sí
vamos a este segundo punto canales de
comunicación recuerden que hace un
momento les dije que por favor y más sin
ninguna caja fuerte donde estaban
ciertas herramientas para alcanzar todas
sus metas y sus sueños pues justamente
vamos a eso en esta es la clave recuerda
que hay tres canales principales las de
pensamiento es una combinación de
imágenes internas sistema de
representación visual
además también sensaciones internas
sistema de representación sensorial y
también sonidos internos sistema de
representación auditivo visual sensorial
y auditivo hay más factores alrededor de
estos y representación interna externa
analógica tonal digital una serie de
factores adicionales pero con que te
sepas esto es más que suficiente
a ver cómo funciona en la lectura en la
literatura de programación
neurolingüística o de neurociencias
puedes encontrar esta información con
estos nombres sintaxis mentales porque
verbal o prestador verbal es visual
sensorial auditivo y comúnmente una
persona tiene más desarrollado un canal
que otro podrás encontrar personas que
son más visuales menos sensoriales menos
auditivos otras más sensoriales menos
visuales menos auditivas e imagínate
todas las combinaciones que pueden salir
de eso en general tenemos personas que
son más de unos menos de otros menos de
otros si tú me preguntas existirán
personas que tienen lo visual y
sensorial totalmente equilibrado pues si
existen son menos del 5% de la población
mundial y algunas personas les dicen
genios o por si acaso genios para nada
te garantiza el éxito en tu vida de
hecho nuestra historia está llena de
genios que han terminado lamentablemente
sus días
paupérrimo porque porque esos genios no
pudieron desarrollar las habilidades
blancas para poner toda esa genialidad
justamente en una plataforma que los
haga crecer
para que puedan identificarlos y esto
sea mucho más fácil para ustedes y poder
identificar las personas visuales
sensoriales auditivas yo te voy a dar un
caso en la vida cotidiana las personas
tu puedes encontrarlos en los centros
comerciales
imagínate que aquí está el anaquel donde
están los equipos de sonido la persona
que es muy muy muy visual para iniciado
para brasil
y solamente va a estar observándolo si
viene el vendedor incluso algo está no
solamente estoy mirando y va a ver los
tamaños los colores las formas y en base
a lo que ve compra toma su decisión de
compra en base a lo que observa el que
sensorial para limón aquel aunque le
ponga son tardes de ot de este tamaño y
de sensorial lo que va ser el agarrarlo
por qué porque si no toca no dibuja una
realidad de su cerebro y qué pasa con el
objetivo es y se acerca y pregunta por
las caretas características y beneficios
y espacial lo que escucha entonces dice
a lo como toma su decisión en base a lo
que escuche esto también lo pueden ver
en la vida cotidiana en la vida de
pareja si por si acaso cualquier
parecido con la realidad
purita coincidencia si una pareja visual
se casa como una pareja sensorial visual
o la visual como quieres ver su casa
arreglado ordenada la lente aspira dos
horas de alfombra el que sensorial no le
importa eso quiere solamente sentir su
campo con su casa cómoda
llama cubriendo el dormitorio la persona
que es visual para arreglarse y verse
bien y la persona sensorial llega yo sé
que ustedes no son de estas personas que
van a hacer esto que voy a describir en
este momento entre hecho un zapato kaká
hecho del zapato para ella mira no se
sienta se desparramen un mueble y poner
a todos encima de la mesita el lado del
centro de un patín globo está para la
cocina y es esa persona que teje el pan
abierto la cuchara dentro de la mayonesa
y derrama toda la bebida y acepto un
desastre bajan la persona que es muy
visual en esos hechos aparece y le dice
cosas como estas mira nada más y no ves
no exijas en qué término hablo visuales
y la persona sensorial le va a contestar
en términos sensoriales siéntete
tarantino tranquila una persona viene a
su casa a sentirse como hablo en
términos sensoriales y está en la vida
laboral es muy similar
imagínate una vez no encontrarán un
proceso de coche para altos ejecutivos y
un gerente general le da a la gerente de
operaciones un encargo que le dé un
informe muy detallado ellos no se
llevaban muy bien entonces la gerente
dijo este es mi momento de lucir me le
voy a demostrar la buena trabajadora que
soy si queda muy buena entonces qué pasa
si amanece como tres días gasta como 25
horas haciendo este trabajo se baje el
excel hace todos los gráficos que te
puede marginar incluso hasta con
photoshop y le entregue el día lunes
ese informe totalmente detallado el
gerente no toman días extra muy bien
cuéntame dime pero jefe mire lo que pasa
es que la figurita ha sido que la
figurita pero fuente dime quiere
escucharle
salió molestísima de la reunión que
sucedió ella era muy visual y él era muy
auditivo los entrenamos con respecto a
estos temas y a los 15 días le vuelven a
pedir un informe invirtió solamente
cuatro horas ya 95 que sucedió de baile
entregue el informe
y aquí tiene el informe pero déjeme
decirle que he encontrado a el cedé y
además de eso es muy bien ha traído tres
puntos que hay que tomar la atención x y
z y finalmente las oportunidades mejores
escúchame bien oído es uno dos y tres y
el gerente general dijo guau nunca había
recibido un informe que sonará tan bien
incluso habló en términos
visuales auditivos o sensoriales depende
del canal estos son algunas personas
hablan según su sistema de
representación si es visual visual o
sensorial sensorial auditiva y todas las
combinaciones que te puedas imaginar
finalmente para terminar y para acabar
esta exposición le voy a contar una
historia una historia que me voy a
permitir leerlo
en tailandia se habla de niños que
aprenden a dirigir elefantes de carga de
gran tamaño simplemente utilizando una
rama pequeña de madera que estos
elefantes transportan una gran cantidad
de tronco a lo largo de la jornada de
trabajo será posible alcanzar el más
alto nivel de liderazgo cuando en toda
la organización el líder puede redefinir
desde adentro su verdadero rol si el
líder de acierto percibe como el niño
inconscientemente considera su equipo
como un gran elefante capaz de lograr
muchas cosas si es bien cuidado si allí
del sorteo percibe como el elefante
entonces inconscientemente considera su
equipo como troncos que hay que moverlo
con esta explicación breve y
simplificada ya tienen las dos partes
para poder abrir su caja fuerte tienen
esa clave y yo estoy muy seguro que van
a poder con esa clave comunicarse mucho
mejor para poder tener un mejor trabajo
en equipo y abrir esa caja fuerte en
donde están todas esas herramientas para
conseguir sus metas y sus sueños que si
quieren y además se merece muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]